[Musik]
eine zeitreise vom neunzehnten
jahrhundert ins einundzwanzigste hat
hillsborough in virginia gemacht und so
soll es überall in amerika sein wenn es
noch joe biden geht doch von anfang an
familie marken läuft die dorfstraße
entlang zum park und das ist eine
sensation denn bis vor kurzem war es
lebensgefährlich
17.000 autos donnerten täglich direkt an
den historischen stein häusern vorbei
bürgersteige gab es nicht ebensowenig
wie internet und sauberes leitungswasser
[Musik]
wir haben neue wasserleitungen wir haben
jetzt trinkwasser
früher hat die erzieherin zu den kindern
gesagt wir machen einen spendenlauf für
die kinder in kenia die müssen auch
laufen um wasser zu holen laufen wir
also für kenia und unsere jungs sagten
wieso laufen wir nicht
wir sind dankbar wir können jetzt den
hahn aufdrehen und haben trinkwasser
[Musik]
die infrastruktur schon einige
präsidenten hatten sich die vorgenommen
präsident biden hat ein
billionenschweres gesetz durchs
parlament gebracht sein bisher größter
wurf amerika soll wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben
stolz zeigt bürgermeister roger bands
uns was er geschafft hat jahrzehnte
kämpfte er um gelder mit beiden
infrastruktur gesetz ist dass ab jetzt
einfacher die maroden strommasten vision
unterirdischen leitungen
glasfaserkabel endlich internet bisher
gab es das nur im alten schulhaus der
120 seelen gemeinde während der pandemie
war hier in der aula für viele
dorfbewohner das home office
es ist eine tiefgreifende veränderung
infrastruktur ist ja mehr als
straßenbeläge und unterirdische rohre
sie schafft eine gemeinschaft
wir brauchten ein gigantisches
infrastruktur gesetz für dieses land
seit jahrzehnten und es wird auch der
wirtschaft auftrieb verschaffen
die arbeitslosigkeit ist niedrig die
löhne steigen aber joe biden
beliebtheitswerte sind trotzdem im
keller die hohen preise werden ihm
angelastet die inflation so hoch wie
seit 40 jahren nicht
voll und james sind auch enttäuscht sie
wollten hier in ihrem büro investieren
ein bed and breakfast eröffnen aber
nichts klappt die inflation lässt die
kosten in die höhe schießen und wegen
unterbrochener lieferketten müssen sie
warten und warten ein albtraum
voll und james wollten nach trump von
beiden nur normalität aber der hatte
mehr vor umfassende sozialreformen eine
engagierte klimapolitik
[Musik]
er kandidierte als ein gemäßigter das
war einer der gründe warum er gewählt
wurde und jetzt ist sein fokus nicht
mehr so gemäßigt jetzt ist es anders man
könnte sagen progressiv oder links wie
auch immer man das nennt
ich glaube jetzt geht es vielmehr um ein
politisches vermächtnis als darum leute
zusammenzubringen und einigkeit
herzustellen
eine der eine nation hatte biden vor
augen an diesem punkt bösen abend vor
einem jahr der große versöhner wollte er
sein einer nation die sich selbst
zerfleischt
ich weiß von einheit zu sprechen kann
dieser tage klingen wie die fantasie
eines nahen unsere geschichte war ein
immerwährender kampf zwischen dem
amerikanischen ideal dass wir alle
gleich sind und der harten hässlichen
realität dass rassismus angst und
verteufelung uns auseinander reißen es
ist ein andauernder kampf
und sieg ist niemals gewiss
[Musik]
die herausforderungen sind gigantisch
innen wie außenpolitisch
afghanistan nach 20 jahren krieg ein
rückzug im chaos taliban triumphieren in
amerikanischen humvees menschen die
alles versuchen um mit den amerikanern
rauszukommen und
13 amerikanische soldaten tot seine
feinde bezeichnen sie als beiden store
china hauptkonkurrent im wettbewerb um
wirtschaft und werte auf präsident hiebl
beiden sich in der außenpolitik
konzentrieren aber ein anderer kommt
immer wieder dazwischen
putin ukraine krise gibt es krieg oder
siegt die diplomatie sieg ist niemals
gewiss und bei alldem auch immer corona
über 800.000 tote für jeden ein weißes
fähnchen ein politischer gegner der die
menschen aufhetzt vom impfen abhält und
eine gesellschaft die sich bis aufs blut
streitet wie kann da ein präsident
erfolgreich sein
meine sorge ist dass die amerikaner
jetzt so polarisiert sind dass sie gar
nicht mehr regiert werden können
wenn die menschen unser ganzes
politisches system nicht mehr für
legitim halten und damit auch nicht mehr
die politiker die daraus hervorgehen
dann können wir alles verlieren
denn immer noch glauben 70 prozent der
republikaner
biden habe die wahl gestohlen im ganzen
land gibt es bestrebungen den aufstand
fortzusetzen mit anderen mitteln
wahlgesetze werden verändert willfährige
helfer an verantwortliche stellen
gesetzt es geht um machterhalt um weißen
machterhalt beides wichtigster kampf ist
der um die demokratie
ich glaube nicht dass der präsident
dafür bisher genug getan hast er muss
die angreifen die in den sozialen medien
lügen verbreiten er muss rausgehen zu
den menschen nicht nur nach
naturkatastrophen
sondern er muss seine politik zu den
menschen tragen und er muss dabei auch
in gegenden gehen indem er vielleicht
nicht willkommen ist
selbst wenn joe biden am ende viel
geschafft hat für die menschen in seinem
land infrastruktur sozialpolitik
klimapolitik bleibt die gretchenfrage
nun sag amerika wie hast du es mit der
demokratie
darauf muss joe biden die richtige
antwort finden und sie ist niemals
gewiss
[Musik]